[Music]
we're gonna need a bigger slingshot Fred
we've discovered a third island we need
to put aside our differences and work
together save the world from being
destroyed what we really need is a hero
actually that positions been filled
I have to get a team together we're
busting you out she's super smart wait
who's that and why is she all over these
achievement award I just don't think
this is gonna work okay so what I'm
usually angry walks to herself
left-handed probably with fun being
alone
look back there okay guys
step one travel undetected teeny island
fold the gadgets you'll see here have
been designed with your current mission
in mind first Bing and visit spray how
long does the invisibility last for
forever
wait why Tina we're not gonna be able to
see each other okay what's the plan I
know working with what we get
hickeys challenging us to a breakdance
battle
[Music]
oh it's on Wow love it - I don't know if
I'm gonna fit in your back anyone smell
bacon
hello I know we've had our differences I
come in peace I don't want to see your
face any more than you want to see mine
we're all in danger yeah you know we
have a truth this is not how a truce
work just say what you gotta say read
we've discovered that there's a third
island and they're plotting to destroy
us all
Bird Island give me one good reason why
I should believe you
I'll show you the proof will Team six
[Music]
in honor of Father's Day we're gonna
spend the day with our daddy doing all
the things he likes to do - yourself
Barney we should just make him a card
[Music]
[Music]
it's made red welcome back to bird
island not much has changed i'm of
course still a hero and this warm with
Leonard in the pigs
no end in sight the estupid may hose I
guess birds and pigs will always be
enemies I know we've had our differences
but we've discovered that there's a
third island and their bodies you
destroy us all
is the scary part we need to put aside
our differences and work together are
you freaking kidding me
each of you has been selected because
you're the best in your field poem that
we could find we got to be prepared for
anything
is what my assistant was going to say
[Music]
[Music]
actually I'm in shock this is the
amazing team I've been working around
the clock for well that's disappointing
[Music]
we gotta get that what's going on down
here yeah I'm just gonna
[Music]
there are any good mother Day songs okay
[Music]
for Mother's Day Mother's Day Mother's
Day we go to brunch Mother's Day nope
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no it's mom I love you mommy
[Music]
sometimes a mom hind eggs or not
sometimes um the Easter Bunny comes and
keep putting languge bunny
but then I got lice and then she's got
all curly heel comes Easter bunny
hopping down to everyone's house and
hide every hey she does it again
no looks like a girl it looks like a boy
good boy
yeah that's my boy boy boy boy girl hi
hey it's me
red you know the guy everybody hated who
kind of saved the whole island anyway
war with Leonard in the pigs what are
you gonna do I'm a foodie still going on
those what and BOM and Chuck are doing
whatever they do I eat dirt and me well
I still have some anger issues but I'm
finding healthier ways to deal with it
Fred I know we've had our differences
but we've discovered that there's a
third island maybe one good reason why I
should believe you now show you the
proof will teams
[Music]
really but this is a hundred times
I have to get a team together guys this
is my sister silver we just don't think
you're gonna be compatible with the team
oh wow it is such a pleasure to meet not
you but you I like her we gotta get to
the island is what my assistant was
going to say
[Music]
ready
[Music]
this is the amazing team I've been
working around the clock for well that's
disappointing what we're gonna break in
and deactivate the weapon weight was
amazing we gotta get that key card hello
fellow Eagle God how he's doing a voice
yeah I'm just gonna
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]